hello everybody my name is markiplier
and thank you to EA for sponsoring this
video so that Bob Wade and I can go into
apex legends season 4 there's a new
character of revenant and a new gun The
Sentinel and if you want to play for
yourself there's a link right in the
description below the game is completely
free and in this game I've officially
won my first round of a battle royale
now you may be thinking I am obviously
no expert at battle royale games but let
me tell you in this video I won I won
totally deserved all skill I won finally
after so many years of trying to friends
and apex okay never mind
oh that's a neat skin on revenant lock I
just don't you know I can't play mark I
don't even know who that is the new
sniper rifle I like the trial-by-fire
skin for that a lot not gonna lie dude I
I don't look at the customization stuff
ever yeah he'll use guns non-emergent I
don't really want to use it oh yeah on
his Apple how much is done not that 400
I'm gonna unlock skins what kind of
person do you think I am I don't do that
that's not my style even though I just
unlocked a character but that's I don't
use in-game currency [ __ ] Tom I stop
announcement this is sponsored by EA
Thank You EA for sponsoring I'm excited
I'm excited to play season 4 the
revenant cutscene I guess I saw the
other day it was just it's really cool
if you're not ready wait oh I hit ready
I knew that
it's me oh wow Oh panic or call me edge
Lord Bob I don't know she chose your
altar is a good guy
you're a chunky and you have a shield
you put down a dome shield that's
invincible when it runs out I think it's
natural I'd be the most girthy character
possible ignore the fact that I only
have two I guess I want to see what's up
at the harvester yeah sure it might be
spicy where am I where's a gun I have no
idea
oh I'm gonna punch you I'm punching you
I'm gonna die I'm going what's the whole
team that came to help with the planks
thanks man my box a few slaps I guess
this is really working out I'm here I'm
peeling my banner you're going the wrong
way
yeah that way I think maybe our first
time played together in the new listen I
was thinking maybe no one else knew
about it okay here over here by that
explosion hey you got us you got us
the nearest respawn beacons over here
that one that's not the one that's this
one I don't I don't like this 250 meters
I don't enjoy this 225 this isn't bad if
you just go over here there's a respawn
mechanic in this game
I'm 75 how do I mute your thing it's at
120 no why didn't that work I wanted to
meet your things east by southeast I'm
literally gonna not respond you on
purpose it's a hundred meters away nope
too far no it's outside the building I'm
going the wrong way I mean that's on me
that's on me yeah sure looks good we'd
like to get something you should get us
back over here how do I meet your pings
why cheating I'm reporting you for
feeding all right guys we're the top ten
school they're flying you're flying you
back in yeah we're basically gonna
witness I'm pretty sure oh hell yeah
I'll just wait till big boy Gibraltar
gets a gun then things go crazy oh yeah
daddy gonna lay a smackdown on a manga
lawyers gonna light it up here it's got
a weapons first scrubs most that beats
still the best shotgun in the game
pretty sure it's a simple you got one I
got a simple it has a different kind of
ammo eat a charge you can refill it oh
wait it has you can well guys oh my mind
man well I'm um gonna die now two bad
guys how do you know they're bad I
presume
maybe you're bad well proper behind yeah
we interrupts come come with me from the
south so watch out okay I just don't see
anything I'll have to figure this one
out
there's guy there's multiple teams of
dudes we gotta use our zombie in the
toilets no one come in here go to zone
go to zone yeah okay so the sniper
it has normal sniper rounds and it has
four route
from the clip by me oh I'm getting so
far away from you what happened oh yeah
I was a little far no I'm Derek oh I
forgot how healing works this is a scout
rifle I thought I had the well I'm done
with you I thought I had the the the
light ammo auto rifle I was thinking
which gun I had mmm its Robo crew ouch
oh hey oh crap
Oh Bob I was about to tell you where we
were mark or I needed wait but not mark
that was the problem
I understand now don't like a problem
you should reverse mute that all right
I'm gonna go towards the place that the
train is moving on the train yeah the
train is like hey it's gonna come out
this tunnel we're gonna you imma show
you guys look I'm jump master I'm not
jump amateur I'm jumping master we got
the Train that's actually kind of
impressive she told you guys thanks for
the armor I guess wait that was my arm
ro mo is those my ammos for my gun yeah
I got the new gun next stop victory boy
I mean all off board what's the opposite
of a Lord Pirrie knows some boxes a
sniper scope over here there's guys here
okay we're monkey is ping him I'm
working on it there over there I'm not
seeing nobody I think you're full of it
No
they out here though mmm ooh there's a
whoops that's nothing there's a that's
the gun I dropped cuz someone took my
[ __ ] ammo but it's really nice
Prowler so yeah it's super cool except
it has like 32 shots total I miss a lot
I need here I just hear I just dropped a
heavy ammo that's heavy ammo right yes
well there you are
yeah where you go come back here
yeah he's over there Wow there's someone
shooting up here up on the up there oh
[ __ ] I don't have my oh hello hi nice -
yep sure is where are you going what is
that that's big and scary oh yeah yeah
I'm getting shot at everybody I look
getting shot apparently I can't use my
abilities huh got a good bit of hits
oh that's a grenade armor what kind of
person has armor where'd you go hmm what
ooh
where am I going oh I think they got
gold armor up there
we've been rubbing it up top um they got
they got some kind of black Wow
I got hit guys they're real bad um oh
jeez I'm Oscar oh jeez if you touch it
you enter some kind of special mode
shield hang on guys oh gee I don't
really know how it works guys guys I
gotta cheat right here you're not out
she'd been pursued behind well turn
around and shoot out of bullets me up
guys I'm here right here why are we
still alive because I have a self revive
and they don't know
that was developed don't some repent
open to throw away hi well yeah there
were multiple teams there hey that's the
say that person did the same thing to me
did you do a finisher I didn't do a
finisher oh they did to finish her also
to you yes that's the one that one there
what is the fireworks no it's cool
there's a boat the mirage boy it's
clearly not a boat it's on land
it's a flying boat okay it's clearly by
boat okay that's not a boy touching land
it's hovering at the moment I'm going on
my own
dododo - boo - boo boo boo boo boo boo
do what we do with you booth I do not
know the range on this thing Bob that
standard is I have ammunition for it
where that is DuBose do you guys want
you guys want the first one and then you
would hey it's that gun you wanted yeah
I got one I'm good bro okay I guess
that's the backpack here wait its energy
no it's not energy it's it's weird own
ammo yes
setting all this blue we really need to
move yeah what is this survey weekend
what do they do stick your finger in
there it tells us where the next circle
gonna be doing I'm sticking my finger in
I'm a robot
I stuck my robot part in there and
I don't need to explain the birds and
the robots to you guys do I yeah
actually I think yeah I think she
explained to me the base and the Gees
respawn ship it's totally a respawn ship
there's guys over there where my mark
bro my mark my you that's kind of a big
beefy gun they got there I don't exactly
have a sniper it's more of a assault
rifle so I'm kind of out of my element
here I'm going I'm a countryman the
tiniest little baby gravel just getting
some speed you wanna you want a hot take
mark yeah what's a hot tip I always do
you know if you grapple the ground and
then jump right as you're about to start
yanking dude I already did it you can
you can give me fully going here so dude
I get you ain't every day hey who shot
no that's a gold cargo bot right there
where I just shot it oh there's only
three squads left fYI my no guys hey
look at the loot Pete can you use do you
have your Zeo meant yeah we're ping
where you give us a whole zipper Ino
like bear up on that thing up up top
yeah I think I can if this is gonna do
what I think it's gonna look at wait
keep an eye on the sky and we just went
to get supplies I'd be careful down
there guys there's bad guys oh yeah yeah
of course
it's fine try number two okay it's
possible whoa whoa a little early I am
NOT I really got to work the mechanics
of this grab Larkin give his other zip
line over like there yeah let me just
share
the further one huh yeah sure they sure
this [ __ ] humans what it's like one dude
hiding in a corner we might actually
alternate recharge pack girls that give
it to you look at you look at this guy
where would I be I don't know oh wait
you're Zelda there's a care package
right there that's just so that's just a
map care package well I mean what I'm
saying is no down in the dead center of
the circle on the lowest ground I don't
think you should I'm going for it you
can't tell me who to be and what to do
certainly put your zip line what about
it we got a knockdown shield we got oh
my goodness got it I got a gold chuck
and a mastiff I messed if I have the
Mastiff yes I feel like there's still
another squad oh we should get up top we
should get up on top of a thing okay top
is good being on top is way better than
not good perspective I'm looking in
buildings I'm just gonna kind of look
are they just hiding I'm guessing
they're hiding over there are there I
don't think I can guess sir they're at
spot it over here or here over here look
at okay over here by what by me
I think it's to I think there's two down
there I'm making a maneuver oh [ __ ] too
much maneuver one down one down
it's lifelines up here yep sure is got
him alright we are awesome champions of
the arena I did exactly we earned that
[Music]